you're the worst person to be giving
advice dude you would Outsource your
entire social life if you could let
cloning become available watch how fast
Cody goes straight to it oh yeah because
he's like I need okay I need a social me
I need a me that eats and uh DJ need one
for training the DJ one just stays in
the class and it just waits for the
yearly excess set yeah exactly I'm
talking but if I could have
stand-up Noel and I just sent him out
and I get the game all day that's what
I'm saying I'm with it let's get the
Clones let's get them in here dude I
can't wait if you have clones would you
just hang out with yourself because you
know you best yeah it just it's a matter
of how far you would go with yourself
you know yeah would you ever like
oh no watching porn with the boys no not
sad boys
I mean yeah I guess that's less weird
than what I'm about to say what gang
banging yourself just like you know like
making out you know